welcome back with talk of a general
election mounting what would life look
like under a Labour government would
they deliver brexit if so what kind what
industries would they nationalize how
would they manage our transport
infrastructure to answer some of those
questions I'm joined now by Rachel Masco
who's Labour's Shadow Realm minister and
joins us from New York Thank You Rachel
maskel for talking to us today so let's
start first of all with the fact that
Jeremy Corbyn has been calling for an
election quite vocally recently to
settle all of this brexit uncertainty
are you ready well absolutely we know
now that this treacherous out that the
Prime Minister is about to commit by
taking us out of the European Union with
no deal we must remember that mr.
Johnson was elected by just 90,000
people and as you think that not even a
mandate to really destroy our economy
and we're seeing already the impact of
that with jobs tumbling and the threat
of clearly worse to come
so we believe that we've got the program
for government in fact people have told
us that we're the most prepared
opposition for government that there has
ever been and we've got the policies in
place which will transform people's
lives up and down the country and that's
what will make a real difference whether
it's housing whether it's putting our
NHS back together or investing in our
creeking infrastructure now is the time
for a Labour government and that's what
we're ready to serve our country with
the policies that will make a real
difference for the day to day lives of
people across the country will come to
those policies in a moment particularly
as you mentioned infrastructure but
despite the fact as you say that you
know there are the policies are there
that there are economic question marks
about the UK right now still your
polling is not looking good right now
actually the Tories are looking stronger
than Labour I mean why do you think that
is well clearly mr. Johnson's got a
little bounce at the moment but of
course when people start being the way
that well the way that they're seeing
that the Prime Minister now with no plan
counts
the comprehensive spending review about
investing in the future of our country
and instead just having an election
spending spree people soon come to
realize that this individual is not
acting in the interests of anybody but
himself and the preservation of
conservative party and of course what
labor want to do is make a difference to
people's lives that's why we exist and
that's what we will do in government and
that's why we're hungry to be in power
to run our country in the interests of
the people of this country one
explanation some people have vote for
why the polling isn't looking especially
good right now especially strong for
labour is that no one quite understands
what your brexit position is so if you
will could you just explain it in one
sentence if you will what is Labor's
brexit position well it's very simple
because we understand the devastation
that No Deal will bring to our country
and and when Parliament has voted
against New Deal
we absolutely will not recklessly take
our country out of the European Union
but more than that we want the country
to determine its future we believe that
this question now it needs to go back to
the countries so that the people can
decide and we've said that in a referent
we'll be campaigning to remain in the
European Union but not just remain to
reform because labor is about performing
whether locally nationally across Europe
or internationally where the party that
want to see will reform and change so
that the institutions work for people
our country we can repair the public
services and make sure we're making the
investments for future jobs and the
future prosperity of our country ok so
let's assume that Labour does win the
next election you're in governments what
are you going to do with the railways
are you going to be nationalizing
well we put forward a new program of
public ownership not going back to the
old models of privatization but one
where we see real democratization but
also devolution across the railway
joining back together track and train
making sure that the railway can work as
one over the last year we've seen a
billion pounds worth put out in in
compensation even over the last week
we've seen will problems on a rail
network we need our transport system to
work for everybody
interconnected with buses and active
travel cycling and walking so that we
can make sure that people can get to
their destination without that stress
which everybody feels as they get on the
railway system at the moment okay so so
there's another question which is how
long it's going to take John MacDonald
said last year that potentially this
could be done in the space of one
parliamentary term five years he said
you were working on the details so you
know that was a year ago presumably
you've seen the detail now how long is
it going to take well we know that we
want to get on with this we are going to
be impatient in government and that's
why first piece of matter is to make
sure that we get that well we'll get on
straight away with putting a railway
system back together and our whole
transport system it must remember the
buses as well which a real mess the
routes aren't going down there the
journeys that people want to travel we
want to give real power to local
authorities to be able to put a
public-service back just specifically my
question how long is it going to take
yep and I've said we're going to get get
on with that immediately first Queen's
speech will be pressing ahead with
changing the legislation and then
bringing immediately the railway system
back together into one public body which
then we can bring the regions of the
bulb that sounds it sounds rather like
you don't know how long it sounds rather
but you don't know it's way too straight
note well we don't have time to waste so
we'll bring that under a public
ownership model
but obviously when franchises are
relinquished in the government aren't
issuing new franchises now they're just
giving direct awards so that will pace
in the process to make sure that we've
got one railway system moving forward
but I mean again okay so we'll leave
that question of how long it's going to
take it sounds like it's gonna be longer
than immediately because you've gotta
wait for those franchises to expire now
what about you said joining track and
train are you going to nationalize the
trains as well as the operating company
so you talked about the operating
companies what about the actual trains
themselves are we going to be bringing
them back into public ownership well at
the moment we have to look at who owns
the rolling stock and they belong to
these companies which we're paying about
a third additional to lease those trains
so of course we want to own our assets
because that ultimately means we're
saving money for the taxpayer we will be
buying back the rolling stock it's not a
case of buying back it's about obviously
as we've investing in the rolling stock
that we will own that in the public
hands as opposed to in these lease
companies which are owned by hedge funds
which clearly are not acting in the
interest so how much will that cost how
much will that cost Rachel mascot right
back those trains to get the trains in
public hands as I've said the whole
program it's not going to cost we can't
just pull out little bits the whole
program it's not going to cost because
what it will bring it's about a third
saving which is being wasted at the
moment we hear it from the rail industry
themselves the stop-start approach it's
really costing the rail industry and
it's costing jobs as well with the
switching on and off of programs so our
investment it's very much about reusing
the resource in a smarter way and that's
why it's not about the expense it's
about the structures that will make the
difference to the public to have their
smooth journeys every day but it does
sound rather as if we don't really have
all of that detail we don't know at
least you don't know how long it's going
to take we don't know how much it's
going to cost to bring those to bring
those trains unter into public ownership
and there is something at least we do
the funding well yeah okay right but
there is something weird you know which
is about the performance of the
nationalized bits of the railway and I
just wonder whether you know looking at
there is one line for instance ln er the
old virgin
east coast that was brought back into
public ownership just last year i wonder
do you know given given that we have a
test case for how good the government
could be at running one of these railway
networks do you know whether it has done
better since becoming estates owned
enterprise or worse well what we know is
we're not going to maintain this model
of the railways because specifically has
the not has the northeast has the north
east line but perform better or worse
under public ownership well there have
been some problems we recognize that not
least there form its figures won't be
that great because of the disaster a
customer always under Chris Grayling who
you know we know lost may the train just
simply didn't run
so obviously the performance figures
have been hit because of the way the
worse in terms of cancellations worse on
most metrics since going into public
ownership which just raises the question
why is the government able to do this
better know in the private sector as I
explained it's because of the disaster
which Chris Grayling brought about
through the the timetable changes
completely unplanned and with his
interference we won't be seeing that
we'll see the real integration the
connectivity walk together across our
railway system so those questions will
not be the same under a Labour
government we're not talking about a
Chris Grayling failed model we're
talking about a Labour strong model of
interconnectivity with the experts
running train service and they when we
talk to the industry they're excited
about what we want to achieve